my goal is to not actually do any
measurements other than using pie so the
entire thing is going to be pie based
we get the circumference in the exact
number of pies okay we'll take we get
the diameter and number of pies divide
one by the other we get pie
pie was historically rarely calculated
this way because it's notoriously
inaccurate
to try and get i know where it is it's
notoriously inaccurate to try and
calculate pi
by measuring a circle
to get any kind of accuracy on our final
answer we have to be as precise as we
can be
this is this is a mild problem because i
want to go from from the very edge of
the circle but as you can see i've
positioned all the pies exactly on the
line as if they're little mini tangents
so i'm going to have to move these two
out
and then i can start doing the diameter
exactly on the circumference there like
that
so that's 84
and one third 264 and two-thirds pies
around we know the diameter is 84 and a
third pi to get pi we just divide the
circumference by the diameter okay and
if we actually work out what that is
equals
that's really good pie from pies we got
3.13834 which is approximately 3.14
so using pies
we've got pie to be 3.14 we i i'm a very
happy man right now
with the diameter and if i know that
ratio i can just measure the diameter
that's the easy bit to measure
the center point will be my pen and the
outside will be the chalk
so the pies in theory
are a fairly consistent size so they're
all
yeah they're about the same okay